jo liebe freunde der gepflegten
redewendung er kommt pietro lombardi der
dsds gewinner und wenn ich da im vorfeld
ein bisschen aufgeregt bin dann habe ich
vögel im bauch mir geht der arsch auf
grundeis und in erwartung dieses
interviews da lach ich mir auch ein
blatt ab denn das hat dieter bohlen
versprochen er wird die lustigsten
interviews geben also genau der richtige
für clixoom und für eure nutzerfragen
kreativ sollen sie sagen wie immer und
da bin ich echt happy was dein letzter
zeit seien zusammengekommen ist dann
video fragen am besten stellen also hier
ziemlich auf dem linken im video klicken
und den info text
unten lesen und ich bin gespannt und
denke mal pietro lombardi wird
baugerüste staunen bei euren fragen